amelia show me what you brought home  oh no no wait wait wait wait wait  what what did dad say when you brought  them home he uh  what's up oh my god so i was in the  garage  and uh walked in  said hey dad guess what and he goes what  and i show him the cats and he goes  no i'm not getting more cats while  yelling going down the stairs i didn't  hear the rest of it but hey it was funny  but it was mom there yeah she actually  wants them yeah what did mom say make  sure you get them checked by the vet  and where'd you find them road oh like  the side of the road yeah they went home  from school you're just like driving  yeah  and how old are they  five to six weeks are they boys or girls  boy girl and how many cats total do we  have now  what about blackhawks  ranks  eight cats yes  okay guys